un effort de guerre à grande échelle ce
sont les mots de joe biden au lendemain
de son investiture
lors d'une conférence de presse à la
maison blanche le président américain
décidé à affronter l'épidémie de kovy 19
face au constat d'échec de son
prédécesseur donald trump les hôpitaux
n'ont plus de lits les entreprises sont
fermées pour de bon les écoles sont
prises entre deux feux
et bien que le vaccin donne tant
d'espoirs son déploiement a été un échec
lamentable jusqu'à présent premier acte
de ce plan de bataille accélérer la
vaccination et apporter un renfort
matériel aux hôpitaux
notre plan commence par la mise en place
d'une campagne de vaccination agressive
sûr et efficace pour atteindre notre
objectif d'administrer 100 millions de
vaccins au cours des 100 premiers jours
de mon mandat
nous en sommes aux premiers jours ce
sera l'un des plus grands défis
opérationnels que notre nation n'ai
jamais entrepris
parmi ces décisions l'obligation du port
du masque dans tous les bâtiments
fédéraux
autre mesure phare des tests et une
quarantaine imposée aux voyageurs
entrant sur le territoire américain
les personnes qui prennent l'avion à
destination des états unis depuis un
autre pays devront effectuer des tests
avant de monter dans l'avion et se
mettre en quarantaine à leur arrivée en
amérique une série de mesures au moment
où les états unis franchissent la barre
des 400 mille décès depuis le début de
la pandémie
prochaine étape pour le démocrate
convaincre le congrès de voter son plan
de relance de 1900 milliards de dollars
pour sortir le pays de sa pire crise
économique depuis les années 30